pas devenir astronaute si on a déjà eu
des caris par exemple que tu racontes
ouais c'est vrai alors des caris euh
c'est vrai que je le dis comme ça après
je crois que c'est plutôt des plombage
mais bon en général ça va ensemble enfin
je sais pas euh pourquoi parce que quand
on a une dépressurisation justement
c'est comme dans un cockpit d'avion et
que la pression soudainement baisse et
que à l'intérieur de cavité qu'on peut
avoir bah notamment dans les dents parce
que euh elle reste la même parce qu'elle
a pas eu le temps de de baisser de
s'égaliser ben ça fait un peu bouchon de
champagne et euh et on a on a les
plombages qui peuvent sauter donc on
imagine on est en train de faire face à
une situation d'urgence et tout d'un
coup paf un truc énorme douleur donc
c'est un peu une contreindication